you know I'm starting to think call me
crazy I'm starting to think that the
Republicans don't like President Obama
and that President Obama doesn't like
the Republicans I have a feeling on this
one John Boehner he he was given a
little speech about immigration to some
Republicans the other day and he had
this to say about the president the
president the other hand has ignored the
will of the American people and he's
refused to listen he himself or his
decision to take unilateral and on
immigration action he himself said
exceeded his authority and makes it
harder for the American people and our
elected representatives to trust his
word on any issue okay so I don't want
to make this about the immigration thing
we've talked a lot about that and we'll
do plenty more segments about that but I
want to talk about the trust issue
because of what I was thinking when I
saw that was well I don't trust you and
I don't trust the president really don't
trust any of them and that's how I
wanted to start this thing do you guys
trust any of these people do you trust
Manor any less or more than you trust
Obama or vice versa or any which way you
can say that it's just rhetoric really i
mean its just oh you don't trust him
he's not trustworthy and if you say that
it's sort of deflection and branding
it's it's sort of ridiculous how
marketed this is yeah do you trust these
people do trust politicians no but the
only people I trust less and politicians
are the American people so when it comes
to like you know Obama doing something
that kind of bypasses maybe the the
dumbest voters I'm fine with that too
yes I don't really trust anyone yeah I
was a lot of x-files growing up so I
learned my lesson so most of your
political beliefs are based in the
x-files oh absolutely what that
something's out there he's out there
trust no one yeah something about little
green men so I when I was watching this
clip and there's a lot more where he
goes into the immigration stuff in
executive action and yes many times
Obama said that he doesn't have the
power to do it and now of course he's
going ahead and doing it so what does
that say just about our system that
everyone lies like we got an election
coming and you know 2015 is gonna be a
big year for the 2016 election my
suspicion is that we're just gonna hear
lies for a year it's gonna be the year
of the lie do you act like you've never
heard of this before it seems worse to
me now is it may become more of an adult
or something I don't know
it just seems like that we've gotten to
a point and I think this is partly an
obama thing where i wanted to believe in
him so much and now i've just seen that
everyone including this guy they just
lie so we're just gonna hear a lot of it
next maybe that is that disillusionment
I mean I think people had a lot of
probably way too much faith in Obama as
he's proven but that doesn't mean he's
the one bad guy it's theirs it just it's
a pool of that oh yeah I have the low
guys yeah I have no love for John
Boehner it's politics just a big soap
opera that's what I really think like
they don't really talk about stuff
really they weren't really going to the
room and work out the stuff anymore
right they just sort of late and it's
it's actually a lot easier for me to
understand as a TV viewer so I
appreciate okay so let's let's put it in
your spot no I'm great this is great
like we can just keep talking about lies
and deception and not actually the
issues and I'm totally fine with that
but isn't that what they want in a weird
way like in the old days they used to
talk about how Bill Clinton used to like
actually go into a room with Newt
Gingrich and really like a work out
policy and I feel like these days that's
just not something that they can you
picture Obama and Boehner in room really
like I feel like they don't even be they
act like children around each other ya
know he's I don't want to talk work with
him ya mean no like and it's it's sort
of yeah your idiot you're right it has
gotten maybe more more of like a rivalry
more more partisan than it should be
yeah um we're in like season like what
season are we in love it I love you guys
it's like we've jumped the shark like so
many times I guess I just don't worry
about anymore yeah if you give me a show
that we can really relate this to that
really jumped the shark or I guess we
could use happy days after the jerk
jumping right literally the show fell
and that's where we learned the phones
this'll president I mean he's like 80
years old I would vote for Henry Winkler
well major Beauty Winkler sure but the
funds is you know in real time as
probably should be dead by now yeah so
final thought on this when every time I
see these types of things it makes me
think that maybe we need a little bit of
what they have in Europe which is the
where they have a president that's just
like the the figurehead and the Prime
Minister that's actually doing this
stuff and I feel like maybe we need a
little of that because we want obama to
be like our rock star and the guy that
plays basketball and he was cool with
weed and blah blah blah but then we also
want him to be the president do you
think maybe we need I thought we had
that
thought like Oprah was our figure and
then everyone else is just kind of doing
other stuff behind the scenes that's
that's fair do you think what do you
think I think it's possible for him to
do both yeah it's isn't it too much and
hard what is it he cool yeah but I don't
know I think he spends too much time
trying to be cool and not enough time
trying to get its branding it's all
brand yeah it's all [ __ ] so you
don't think we should split the
presidency into a prime ministership
this is the second time I've been on
that show this showing you back I really
want to get that out of YouTube I really
really want who think I want it anyway I
don't trust any of them